get the most out of Medicare.
Call now.
AINSLEY: THIS IS A FOX NEWS
ALERT.
MAJOR NEWS IN THE RACE FOR A
COVID-19 VACCINE DRUG GIANT
MODERNA ANNOUNCING THEIR VACCINE
TRIALS SHOW THAT IT IS NEARLY
95% EFFECTIVE.
JOINING PFIZER AS A LEADER IN
THE PUSH TO END THIS PANDEMIC.
BRIAN: WOW, THAT IS GREAT NEWS.
HEALTH AND HUMAN SERVICES ALEX
AZAR JOINS US WITH AN UPDATE.
MR. SECRETARY, THIS IS NOT
TOTALLY SURPRISING.
WE HAVEN’T GOTTEN THE DETAILS
YET.
BUT NOW WE HAVE TWO VACCINES.
WHEN COUNTY AMERICAN PEOPLE BE
ABLE TO EXPECT TO MAKE THAT
CHOICE WHICH ONE THEY WANT?
>> WELL, THANKS TO PRESIDENT
TRUMP’S OPERATION WARP SPEED,
THAT CHOICE IS COMING VERY SOON.
YOU KNOW, THIS IS REALLY AN
HISTORIC DAY.
THIS IS THE VACCINE THAT
PRESIDENT TRUMP PARTNERED WITH
MODERNA ON JANUARY 13TH AT OUR
NIH LABS NOW OVER 90% EFFECTIVE
VACCINE IN ONE OF THE LARGEST
CLINICAL TRIALS EVER.
NOW WE HAVE PFIZER, WE HAVE
MODERNA AND THANKS TO PRESIDENT
TRUMP’S VISION WE HAVE BEEN
MAKING BOTH OF THOSE AND FOUR
OTHER VACCINES AT COMMERCIAL
SCALE PRODUCTION.
WE BELIEVE WE WILL HAVE ENOUGH
FOR 20 MILLION AMERICANS TO GET
VACCINATED IN DECEMBER.
STEVE: OKAY.  MR. SECRETARY,
LAST WEEK WHEN THE PFIZER NEWS
CAME OUT WHERE IT WAS 90%
EFFECTIVE.
THE STOCK MARKET WENT UP LIKE
1,000 POINTS THAT DAY.
CLEARLY THIS IS GOING TO IMPACT
THE STOCK MARKET AS WELL AND
IMPACT PEOPLE’S LIVES.
PEOPLE ARE SAYING I CAN EITHER
GET THE ONE THAT’S 90% EFFECTIVE
OR 95% EFFECTIVE.
THE PROBLEM IS I HAVE READ THAT
THE PFIZER VACCINE HAS GOT TO BE
STORED AT 70 DEGREES BELOW ZERO
AND A LOT OF PLACES DON’T HAVE
THAT KIND OF FACILITY WHEREAS
PERHAPS THE MODERNA IS EASIER.
SO FAST FORWARD TO WHEN THIS IS
MASS PRODUCED.
WILL SOMEBODY BE ABLE TO GO TO
THE WALGREEN’S AND SAY GIVE ME
THE PFIZER OR GIVE MEE THE
MODERNA?
>> THAT’S A GREAT QUESTION AND
THE MODERNA ONE IS MORE FLEXIBLE
IT.
CAN BE KEPT IN A REGULAR FREEZER
REFRIGERATION.
IT’S GOING TO BE AMENABLE TO
THAT PROGRAM WE ANNOUNCED LAST
WEEK GOING TO YOUR LOCAL CHAIN
OR COMMUNITY PHARMACIST AND
GETTING VACCINATED THE PFIZER
ONE GOING TO BE GOOD FOR BIG
INSTITUTIONAL VACCINATIONS SAY A
WHOLE HOSPITAL SETTING.
SEVERAL NURSING HOMES AT ONCE.
AINSLEY: MR. SECRETARY, WHAT DO
YOU SAY ABOUT SCHOOLS?
I KNOW GOVERNOR CUOMO HAS SAID
IF IT DOESN’T GET UP TO 3%
SCHOOLS CAN STAY OPEN.
ONCE IT HITS 3% IN NEW YORK
SCHOOLS HAVE TO CLOSE.
HE SAID LET’S LOOK AT EACH
SCHOOL INDIVIDUALLY BECAUSE SOME
ARE HOT SPOTS AND SOME ARE NOT.
THIS IS AN ISSUE THAT AMERICANS,
DEMOCRATS AND REPUBLICANS WOULD
ALL SAY KEEP THOSE SCHOOLS OPEN,
AT LEAST THE MAJORITY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> IT’S RIDICULOUS TO CLOSE OUR
SCHOOLS.
IT’S NOT DRIVEN BY SCIENCE AND
DATA OR EVIDENCE.
LOOK AT THE EUROPEANS.
THEY ARE EXPERIENCING 45% MORE
CASES PER CAPITA ON THE DAILY
BASIS THAN THE U.S.
THEY ARE MAKING IT A PRIORITY TO
KEEP THEIR SCHOOLS OPEN.
BECAUSE THE SCHOOLS K THROUGH
12, UNIVERSITIES, THESE ARE NOT
MAJOR VECTORS OF DISEASE
TRANSMISSION.
OUR WORKPLACES ARE NOT.
OUR AIRLINES ARE NOT.
IT’S INDOOR GATHERINGS WHERE WE
LET OUR GUARD DOWN, DON’T WEAR A
MASK.
DON’T KEEP SOCIAL DISTANCE.
AND OUR GOVERNORS KEEP GOING AT
OUR SCHOOLS AND OUR KIDS.
THERE IS REAL HARM TO OUR KIDS,
THEIR MENTAL HEALTH, THEIR
PHYSICAL HEALTH, THEIR EMOTIONAL
WELL-BEING.
WE SHOULDN’T BE CLOSING OUR
SCHOOLS.
BRIAN: SOMEONE HAS GOT TO GET
THAT MESSAGE TO GOVERNOR
WHITMER.
SHE HAS CLOSED HIGH SCHOOL AND
COLLEGES.
THEY HAVE TO GO REMOTE.
INDOOR LIMITED TO 10 OUTDOOR 25.
DOCTORATE ALSO A COME OUT AND
SAID PEOPLE SHOULD REVOLT.
NOT GET VIOLENT BUT REVOLT AND
SAY THIS IS NOT ACCEPTABLE.
THEY HAD THE STRICTEST LOCKDOWN
AND THEIR NUMBERS ARE GOING UP
LIKE OTHERS ARE GOING UP.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THE SAID THAT
TO THE GOVERNOR?
>> I WOULD STY EVERYBODY BE
GUIDED BY SCIENCE AND DEMOCRAT
TANTD DATA SUPPORTS KEEPING OUR
SCHOOLS OPEN.
LOOK AT THE EUROPEANS LIKE I
SAID, THEY ARE ABOUT AS CAUTIOUS
AND AS SCARED OF THEIR SHADOW AS
ANYBODY CAN BE, AND THEY ARE
KEEPING THEIR SCHOOLS OPEN.
BECAUSE THEY KNOW SCHOOLS ARE
SAFE.
YOU CAN RUN THEM SAFELY.
ANY INSTITUTION WHERE YOU HAVE
LEADERSHIP FOLLOWING GOOD PUBLIC
HEALTH GUIDANCE ON HOW TO KEEP
SOCIAL DISTANCE, WEAR FACE
COVERINGS.
WE HAVE KNOWN THIS CAN BE DONE
SAFELY AND THESE INSTITUTION
DOES NOT NEED TO BE SHUT DOWN TO
KEEP US SAFE.
STEVE: MR. SECRETARY, REAL
QUICK, 10 DAYS FROM TODAY IS
THANKSGIVING.
A LOT OF COLLEGE KIDS ARE GOING
TO BE COMING HOME.
I JUST READ THAT BOSTON
UNIVERSITY IS SUGGESTING PEOPLE
NOT LEAVE CAMPUS.
THEY HAVE A FRIENDS GIVING.
OTHER SCHOOLS ARE ENDING IN
PERSON LEARNING AT THE
THANKSGIVING HOLIDAY AS WELL.
THEY ARE JUST GOING TO GO HOME.
BUT FOR PEOPLE WHOSE CHILDREN
ARE AWAY FOR THEM TO COME HOME
FOR A COUPLE OF DAYS, WHAT SORT
OF PRECAUTIONS BECAUSE MY WIFE
AND I HAVE BEEN TALKING ABOUT
WHETHER OR NOT WE SEE OUR OWN
KIDS OVER THANKSGIVING FOR THE
LAST TWO WEEKS.
>> WELL, YOU WANT TO LOOK AT
WHAT IS GOING ON AT THAT SCHOOL.
WHAT KIND OF CASE POSITIVITY
THEY ARE HAVING.
IS THERE IS A LOT OF INFECTION
THERE?
MOST OF OUR UNIVERSITIES WE ARE
NOT SEEING -- UNIVERSITIES WHO
HAVE WEEKLY TESTING HAVE SOME OF
THE LOWEST CASE RATES OF ANY
PLACES IN THE COUNTRY.
SO YOUR KIDS MAY BE SAFER THAN
YOU ARE, FRANKLY, IN GETTING
TOGETHER.
LOOK AT THOSE CIRCUMSTANCES.
AND JUST USE GOOD COMMON SENSE.
LOOK AT CORONAVIRUS.GOV, CDC GOT
GOV FOR OUR BEST ADVICE ON HOW
TO STEER THROUGH THANKSGIVING
AND CHRISTMAS AND WHAT THE
DIFFERENT MITIGATION STEPS YOU
CAN TAKE AT HOME.
VERY COMMON SENSE THINGS LIKE
OPENING THE WINDOW IF YOU CAN
EATING OUT DOORS IF YOU CAN
MINIMIZING THE NUMBER OF FOLKS
DEPENDING ON YOUR OWN VERMONTS.
JUST LOOK AT THE CIRCUMSTANCES
AND USE COMMON SENSE.
STEVE: ALL RIGHT.
THANK YOU.